what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so our indie videos they're usually
just kind of videos I just go out there
and it's just like things that I think
are kind of cool and they're basically
comics not published by Marvel or DC
that's really kind of like the whole
idea of indie stuff value now I would
consider to be like the third biggest
publisher in terms of shared continuity
I mean overall image is bigger but image
does not have a shared continuity you're
never going to see spawn crossover with
east of West which is kind of
disappointing because that would be
really really interesting to see I think
you actually be really kind of cool but
the fact remains here that there are a
line of comics about the aliens the
xenomorph it was actually really cool um
oh it's kind of thinking about this with
regards to alien come in coming out
which I'm really really excited about
but the funny thing about this is that
these comics basically treat everything
after James Cameron's aliens to be
non-existent which is what we all pretty
much do anyway so because of that um
it's kind of weird in this story you
have Hicks and you have Newt but the
problem is they reference Hicks as Wilks
and they reference Newt as Billy we're
not going to do that we're going to call
them Hicks in news because that's the
name that most everybody knows which by
the way if you have never seen aliens 1
y & 2 you're missing out like that's one
of the very few like there was a really
good segment and scream where they were
talking about like sequels very few
times do sequels ever surpass their
original but aliens does it Terminator 2
does it ah the new Blade Runner movie
will not do that but you know it happens
from time to time and it's actually kind
of a cool thing to see the reason why
though the reason why these characters
are called wilkes and Billy is because
of the fact that these came out almost
immediately after aliens because aliens
was such a huge hit it was a blockbuster
film and is still one of the greatest
movies ever made to this day is almost
as good as Jaws not as my quite but
almost as good as Jaws but the fact
remains here that because of the fact
that alien 3 came out and depicted the
death of Hicks in the death of Newt
basically Dark Horse had to go back and
just like rework these comics and change
the name to sit into the continuity the
good thing is that we don't have to do
that so the cool thing is that this
initially picks up with Newt and
actually takes place about ten years
after the events of aliens and what we
end up finding out here is that Newt is
basically in a mental institution she's
in an asylum now when I told explicitly
why right off the bat all were really
told is that she's basically confined
here because she couldn't cope with her
life really with
the things that were going on around
here now in terms of what she was having
a hard time coping with this is the
opening salvo of this story Newt is
basically suffering from night terrors
and what I mean by that is she's talking
to her psychiatrist and she basically
talks about a dream she has and the
dream takes place on lv-426 the planet
where aliens - took place but what she
does is she basically tells us a story
about her and a couple of her friends
who were camping this is kind of cool
because it shows us how things work in
relation to the whole alien mythos I you
know in the far-flung future in excess
of the year 2100 but it's basically this
idea the things that we do like camping
stuff like that are long since gone that
they're not really like fireplaces and
things like that really like campfires
or anything
instead everything's just really
technologically advanced and so the
little little tidbits of what we
consider to be you know advanced life
now are considered to the Arctic here in
the future but the issue is that they
all start taking turns telling stories
and when it comes for a news opportunity
they're like surely you know a scary
story and she starts running over the
events of lv-426 basically what we saw
in the movie which is to say we saw the
special edition that you know her
parents are basically tasked with going
out and searching a ship which was done
but you know I guess the messes were
sent by Burke and and the result was
that her father was basically attached
by a facehugger and the infestation
spread throughout the entire the entire
compound but in the midst of work of
this whole dream one is up happening is
her friends basically begin succumbing
to an infestation which is to say aliens
start bursting out of their chests and
of course what this does is it basically
sets the stage for showing that her
character is suffering from issues time
and time again suffering from problems
over and over and over again of course
this leads to her more or less wandering
the halls at least her sleepwalking feel
and in this instance she was caught
beating on a wall in the middle of her
night terrors and so because of this um
this really begins to shift over to
Hicks himself and hitch suffers the same
fate
he suffers from nightmares the
difference here is that Hicks has the
ability to sort of overcome these or at
least handle them a little bit better
than Newt ever did and the reason why is
because of the fact remember with the
character of noon she was essentially
suffering from all these major issues I
mean she was a little kid but basically
experienced this heinous series of
events but for Hicks he was a colonial
Marine all he knew was conflict and
death and so he was able to adapt to
these nightmares better than better than
Newt was now at this point we switch
over to a shiver - a vessel called
the SS and the Dutton is basically a
ship that serves the purpose of
operating as the Coast Guard and
essentially what we're told here is that
somewhere along the line various ships
when there are tenure was over they were
allowed to basically just kind of crash
land in the earth decaying orbit would
cause the ships to break up when they
hit me it hit the atmosphere or
something along those lines the issue
was that a ship eventually crashed off
the coast of Hawaii and between the
explosion and the nuclear radiation that
was let off because of the
nuclear-powered engine ended up killing
a ton of people in Hawaii and so now
what happens is the Coast Guard
basically goes out to these various
derelict ships who are no longer you
know that are no longer being used
they're basically abandoned blow them up
and then just kind of allow them to
either burn up in the atmosphere
or else just kind of float harmlessly
through space the issue is that when the
crew from the Dutton gets onto this
derelict ship we end up finding out
there's a xenomorph on board now in
terms of how the xenomorph got here
we're really not given an answer where
somebody just told that it was a
stowaway on this one particular vessel
and that make sense just because of the
fact that genomorphs are so prevalent
throughout the other the universe in
terms are really in throughout the
galaxy and so on in terms of the alien
mythos it could have been picked up from
anywhere and so because of that all
these guys on the dutton are killed and
that's really the end of them and so
what we end up finding out is that all
of this has been observed by the
government and what they end up doing is
they basically reach out to Hicks and
the reason why is because of the fact
that where he had been considered a
crazy person before there's now married
to his argument that there are a group
of aliens out there that are basically
able to survive in space they're immune
to almost all conventional weapons save
for fire and high-powered rounds and the
result is that the government now wants
to harness one of these specimens but
where the plot begins to thicken is when
we pick up with a guy by the name of
salvo GA now this guy is basically a
religious fanatic he's a guy who worked
for a company called bio biotech
national or something on those lines the
bio national technology I think of what
it is but basically this was another
company in addition to the government
and bio bio national technically wanted
to grab a xenomorph specimen for
themselves and then use it for their own
ends the issue with this is that
Salvaggio used to work for bio national
but as a guy who was basically previewed
to these different you know xenomorph
seized of an aliens he began to develop
an obsession himself but in his mind it
wasn't about harnessing a xenomorph and
using it for bio warfare instead it was
viewing a xenomorph as like a messiah
doesn't
or basically bring in the true era of a
god so to speak and he would purge all
the non-believers from the face of the
planet earth and so what he ends up
doing is he basically grabs some kind of
a some guy that basically works on the
black market as a tech who's able to
hack into the internet which is highly
monitored by the US government bypass
all these different safeties and
firewalls and begin broadcasting a
message designed to brainwash people who
see it and rally them to his cause so
because of this we end up transitioning
back over to a newt and we kind of jump
back and forth between newt and and
corporal Hicks now with regards to to
newt herself it's really just kind of
her in an institution again just sort of
you know showing us is she's struggling
with the world around her but also the
idea that she's constantly unmet she's
constantly being sedated because of the
fact that she has these outbursts but
there's also a little bit of crookedness
going on here in the sense that she has
a hearing that's coming up that's going
to determine whether or not she's
actually crazy but in order to maintain
itself this mental institution is
essentially going through taking people
people like Newt for example keeping
them sedated and then in the days before
their hearings basically lobotomizing
them saying hey look we had no other
choice she was beyond hope we did
everything we could but it just didn't
work out and even going so far as to
cook the books in order to make it look
like there was never an incidence where
she showed any signs of improvement so
again it's really this idea that we're
going to be see a much darker side of
the story and that new her self is going
to be or at least it's presumed that
she's going to be lobotomised now in
terms of Hicks himself we get for the
most part a bit of a refresher that's
going on here in terms of you know how
he functions and what he does and
different things like that
we basically join him when he's picking
up with a guy by the name of Colonel
Stevens and a guy named uh Nora I think
it's a Oh Nora is how you pronounce it
but regardless it's really just kind of
rehashing things that we've already seen
with regards to his character so we
basically get like a rundown of the
events of aliens but we're also shown a
little bit of what his life was like
before aliens which is to say that he
had a sterling reputation as a Marine in
terms of carrying out the various
missions without error leading his
leading his group were his platoon I
think it's called leading them into
combat situations ensuring people got
out of life the problem is that after
the event of lv-426 his life took a
drastic turn he couldn't cope with life
as it existed around him you know with
everything kind of following it not only
that the people that he knew thought he
was basically tainted
has the event on lv-426 the the
Xenomorphs is somehow contaminated him
and so because of that they would
basically avoid him or else others were
taught him which would lead to like bar
fights and different things like that
and so because of this we actually end
up having Hicks going to visit going to
visit Newt and the funny thing about
this is that Dark Horse kind of teases
the idea that there's a romance between
the two of them now there's actually not
it's really more of like a
father/daughter relationship more so
than anything else but in a lot of ways
she's the only person that really
understands where he's coming from now
this brings into sharp relief the one
question now I'm sure a lot of you have
been asking where is Ellen Ripley Ellen
Ripley is not in this story and Ellen
Ripley fate is never given to us we
never find out what happened sir she's
only referenced once and somebody talks
about you know says the girl and well
you know what happened to her and that's
it that's all we get now she will make a
return but for the sake of this story it
was designed to focus only on corporal
Hicks and n-new now what we end up
finding out here is it with the two of
them talking and basically reconciling
that they're essentially struggling with
everything that's going on they're not
quite able to grasp the gravity of their
situation in terms of you know how far
they've fallen it is to say the
nightmares they have a terrible
experiences they have but the fact that
they're both trying to function at the
same time and trying to keep their lives
going now at this point we jump to the
introduction of a guy named Massie and
those are really kind of like the the
main guys in this story there's savage a
there's Massie
there's Hicks and there's Newt Newt it's
kind of an aside character she'll be
just there until we end up getting out
towards the end of the story but Massie
is a guy who is he's a sociopath he's
crazy as hell but he ended up killing
its comparison when he was a kid he got
an MBA from Cornell in like business law
or something like that he got a law
degree now and then he ended up by
joining the Marine Corps the reason why
is because he just liked killing things
the problem is that he punched out his
CEO when master was basically making the
case that there were you know terrorists
inside of a camp or something like that
the CEO objected Massie knocked out a
CEO and then went through and killed 85
men women and children and so because of
that where he normally would have been
court-martialed by Oh Nash it'll
actually bought out the tribunal and
then hired Massie so that he begets that
are not guilty and then they basically
hired him on and the reason for this is
because bio national is chasing the
government well the government basically
grabs Hicks and you know and says hey
look we want you to fund an expedition
where you are going to go to the
xenomorph home
and you are going to basically bring a
xenomorph specimen back here bio
national already has a specimen and will
actually find out what what specimen may
end up having the bio national already
has a xenomorph their goal is to keep
the government from being involved in
the whole biotech weapons race so they
can in turn sell what they have to the
government so again it's basically a
corporate sabotage is really what
they're going for
but in the midst of this we end up
finding out that Hicks had basically
hacked into the field quest home for the
mentally insane and was monitoring the
various conversations and live feeds
regarding Newt and what we end up
finding out here from Hicks perspective
is that they're going to lobotomize take
away her ability to feel or understand
anything she's going to be a shell of
herself and so in a last-ditch effort
hicks breaks in and actually frees knew
the problem with this is this happens
just before the mission so nobody can
scuttle the mission nobody knows that
she's there he stole her away and then
they take off into space and they
basically exist for about nine months
later now the other half of this is we
also get a little more expansion on
what's going on with the character of
nasi in terms of just how dark he is
where Massie had been hired by bio
national Massey's actions were very
disconcerting and the reason why was
because of the fact that Massey was
basically given information on his
newest mission by bio National which was
to chase after Hicks a ship at the
governor was trying to get to the to the
xenomorph homeworld and the issue with
this was that the message was sent
unencrypted which meant that his wife
and his son saw the message about these
enum Wars and as a result Massey worked
the next of his wife and his son and
then made it look like a double homicide
and the cops helped him to clean it up
so again it was a pre is a pretty dark
scenario a pretty screwed up situation
but at this point we switch over to a
guy by the name of James Lacan ski or
Jim mikowski and this is when we find
out bio nationals basically what it is
they have under their belt in terms of
their own specimen what ended up
happening here and again we're not
really told exactly how this happened
but what ended up happening here is
somewhere along the line Jim Lee Kowski
was basically attacked by a face hunter
and planted with a xenomorph the issue
is that he was brought back by bio
national to their Trenton headquarters
and the result is that they've been
monitoring him every sever since now
there's just as much about science and
research it was anything else's so
they're doing exactly what the
government would have done they will
study Jim to see how easy no more
functions what it does so weird
a little bit of information here by this
day and age it's not anything we don't
already know but back when this
colleague first came out it was a ton of
stuff that nobody knew nobody knew about
the gestation process of the xenomorph
all we really knew is whatever came out
with a special edition of alien 4 we
actually found out that the original
lifecycle of the xenomorph was going to
be that there were basically eggs and
the eggs were going to you know release
facehuggers that would attach to people
in turn there was a give birth to new
xenomorph and then those individuals
would be basically re materialized into
inner cocoons
to keep the entire process going there's
a really really cool scene and the alien
special edition when Ripley goes down to
the cargo hold I think it is and ends up
finding like Dallas and I came over who
the other guy was but ends up finding
Dallas being converted into a cocoon and
she ends up setting him on fire just
because they asked her to you but the
fact remains that it was a pretty
haunting moment but you know this new
this new lifecycle as it was created by
James Cameron which is to say the Queen
you know planting cocoons and then so on
and so forth um this is basically what
they're studying and so in their mind
they don't know how long the gestation
period lasts all they know is that you
know Jim Jim wachowski has been planted
with a xenomorph and at some point it
will emerge from him but even they don't
know how this happens because keep in
mind lv-426 is way out there and with
the exception of people who were able to
gain access to the different to the
various files that were provided by the
federal government picked up by the
government as well as whatever
statements were made by Newt and Hicks
no one really knows how xenomorph
function and so because of that again
it's just as much research and study as
it is anything else and so because of
that's what we end up doing is we
actually jump back over to Hicks only to
find out you know that Colonel Stevens
did not know again that that Newt was on
board but ultimately found a stowaway
and of course for snakes to reveal that
he had brought her on board now in truth
because of the fact that there's so much
politics going on here not much really
ends up playing out that's really just
kind of the idea that Hicks himself you
know is just kind of hey look we can
deal with this when we get back but for
right now we've got more important
things to deal with but in the midst of
all this someone and we don't know who
is going through and killing people on
the ship effectively sabotaging it and
so again it's creating all kinds of
different different in crazy situations
but jumping back over to add to Jim
Mackowski the moment where by the the
xenomorph begins to emerge what he is of
doing is grabbing a gun from one of the
guards and then shooting other guards
and then making his escape going back to
really his wife it seems to be you know
telling her of course that he loves her
and then being recaptured now the way
this is written is actually a little
confusing in the sense that we don't
know this was all in his head
or we don't know if it actually happened
that's kind of the issue here because
he's basically taken by one of the guys
and then he suddenly just jumps back to
the to the table where the xenomorph is
getting ready to break out and it's
basically a repeat of what we saw before
now one of the issue is with the way
this was written back in 1989 is it
wasn't written supremely well and so
because of that there were a few issues
here and there in terms of linking
things up you know for example we jump
over to another section in another event
that's taking place with Hicks but we
don't really know that it's them right
off the bat we simply just kind of have
to look at the environment and then
realize they're on a ship so it's a
little a little while in terms of how it
unfolds but ultimately this xenomorph
actually begins to emerge and the head
of the entire project wants to see the
birthing process and so in the middle of
all this Jim Mackowski actually grabs a
guy pulls his head to him and of course
the xenomorph bursts out you know goes
through the guy's chest kills the head
of the entire operation and then from
there it's basically just keeping the
xenomorph contained so the outbreak on
earth ii the earthly infestation does
not hail from this it's basically them
you know it was a close call the
xenomorph almost got away but it was
basically them able to keep the entire
thing contained and and keep anything
from from going awry
and so what is up happening here is we
end up finding out that we're bio
national was basically keeping this the
xenomorph in stasis that the xenomorph
was a queen and they were allowing it to
molt they were allowing it to go through
its entire process to eventually you
know grow to its full fruition to the
point where it would begin the process
of laying eggs now this is a very
dangerous game and the reason why is
because by national again does not know
exactly how the Xenomorphs work they
have a good idea but they're basically
learning about them as they watch them
so all they know is there's this massive
20-foot Queen seal basically with an
ovipositor planting these eggs all over
the place and they don't really know
what's going to happen I mean they know
that you know if they walk up to one of
the eggs at a facehugger will latch onto
them but they don't know how fast these
things grow what we end up finding out
is that through the actions of selvaggi
and the fact that he's basically amassed
hundreds if not thousands of followers
through his different broadcast that one
of these individuals actually comes up
to the bio National Building where the
Queen alien is being held with a bunch
of explosive
around her waist and blows it up
effectively blowing a hole in the entire
facility and allowing all of salvo Jays
followers and selvaggi himself to enter
the facility now the crazy thing about
this is that it's only at the moment
when he spawned it with a face hugger
DiSalvo J realizes the gravity of his
crimes and his mind he was so far gone
he was so far involved and religious
zealotry that he didn't realize what it
was that he was getting into in his mind
he was able to he was gonna be able to
communicate with a xenomorph he was
going to be able to talk to them he was
going to be able to say hey look you
know you guys can have all these
different people around the world but
don't touch us because we're your loyal
followers we love you but as we know
Xenomorphs are driven by instinct but
this is what selvaggi didn't grasp and
his mind they were intelligent he could
communicate with them so on and so forth
and so again these xenomorph
the face hunters do not differentiate
between selvaggi and anybody else and
all of his followers are basically
attacked now for the crazy people who
were there that's what they were
shooting for in the first place but
because of the fact that you know all
this is basically going crazy and all
that's running amok what isn't happening
is bio national calls in their own guys
and they begin the process of shooting
the place up it's Greek trying to kill
off as many of selvaggi Jays followers
as they possibly can now so Bosnia does
not immediately die instead things are
just kind of going you know kind of
running amok and that's really kind of
it but jump me back to corporal Hicks
jump me back into space again we end up
picking up with the arrival of nasty
Mira mashi was sent by bio National for
the purpose of sabotaging the
government-sanctioned
mission to the xenomorph homeworld in
order grab a specimen for themselves now
with masih coming up what we end up
finding out here is that the person who
was going through and killing people and
basically sabotaging the mission from
the inside was Colonel Stevens Colonel
Stevens has been working for bio
national now we don't know exactly how
they got him money seems to be the most
logical cost but we simply know that
he's working among their ranks the issue
with this is that with Massey being a
new arrival he does not know that Newt
is a stowaway so it's kind of a cool
scenario not only that we also get a few
Easter eggs here in the sense that much
like in the original aliens movie I
guess you know really aliens by James
Cameron
wended up happening as of course we
stumbled across new when she was hiding
out in the various ventilation shafts
that's exactly what happens here knew
basically takes to the ventilation
shafts and begins to play more of a
reconnaissance role
listening to the things that Massey's
saying how Massey's taking taking Hicks
prisoner Col Massey's basically there
too
Bhutan's the mission to kill off all the
Marines different things like that but
it can't be done in a way that looks
legit because remember the government
always keeps tabs on what it is it's
going on so where Stevens was able to
sabotage things to a degree the mission
has to look like a complete and total
catastrophe and so what is up happening
here is nasty basically forces all the
Marines to descend down onto the surface
of the xenomorph homeworld and then
what's going to follow is basically just
a bloodbath and that's exactly what it
is I mean they go in there and they had
no clue what it was or they were getting
into you know now one this is the genome
of xenomorph homeworld which means the
numbers are higher here than anywhere
else that will actually find out later
on and the mo zhee no more comics
assuming that we get that far into it
there is actually a civil war among the
aliens you have the red and you have the
black one and so there's basically kind
of their own little civil war taking
place and it's a really cool built up
and drawn-out concept but the fact
remains here that with masse basically
continuing to hold an exhausted and
watching the events unfold we basically
have you know mute making her presence
here now this is kind of interesting
because remember in Matthew still going
by the idea that this all has to seem
like a catastrophe and so because of
that he actually sets the shift it's
self destruct and what will happen is
it'll basically look like Hicks and all
those guys went to the xenomorph
homeworld xenomorphs basically over land
them and in a last-ditch effort to
ensure the xenomorph wouldn't get back
to earth that they scuttled the mission
and blew up the ship and so again it's
kind of a interesting way for the events
to play out but knew basically ends up
killing killing maceió but then at this
point it's basically kind of recalling
everybody back and trying to get out of
there as best they can the problem is
that multiple people aren't really able
to to make it out on their own
now the craziest thing about this is
that noone herself had actually fallen
in love with a guy by the name of
Bueller and what I did is it created a
source of contention between Hicks and
Newt in the sense that again Hicks
looked at her very much as like a you
know looked at her like a daughter and
so because that it was like seeing his
own daughter basically moving on and
having a relationship different things
like that now I wouldn't deny that there
was some measure of attraction between
Hicks and Newt even if only on the side
of Hicks but the fact remains here that
Bueller had basically shown shown Newt
that there was a better way besides the
cold nature that she'd experienced so
far in terms of you know how brutally
she was treated in which was at the
mental institution the fact that she was
having nightmares all the time he
represented a better life the problem is
that while he was one of the end
vigils who had gone down to the surface
during the whole genome or Pataki we end
up finding out that Bueller is actually
an Android that he's not a human and so
again it's kind of crazy that we get
these cool little just sudden drops
these these kind of crazy moments not
only that we end up finding out that
most of the guys that were alongside
masse were androids now this is very
very smart and it's actually really cool
Androids despite the fact that within
the the the alien mythos you know they
can be programmed really to ensure that
they never harm a person or that a
person is never harmed they can be
reprogrammed they can be reprogrammed to
serve whatever purpose they're
programmed for and so Massey most likely
a really bio national most likely have
them set up to follow Massey's orders
without question and so of course when
he basically sent all them down to the
surface alongside the Marines and
basically served the purpose of the
Marines being bait and so it ended up to
you know end up with the Marines all
being executed and then the entire thing
are you know really kind of coming to a
close the problem is that the story
begins to get a little crazy get a
little wonky once we end up with the
arrival of one of the space jockeys now
keep in mind this is long before
Prometheus and Prometheus actually
changed a lot of the stuff that was here
when this story first came out there was
no Prometheus all we knew is that there
was just the space jockey in the first
Alien movie when they got inside the
ship and that was it we didn't know
anything else and so because of that
this space jockey basically demonstrates
telepathic abilities and what it does is
it communicates directly with with Newt
and it both reads her mind and feeds her
information at the same time and what it
basically tells her is that the iconic
space jockey the one that we think of
when we think of the first alien was the
friend of this existing space jockey
more or less so this jockey basically
showed up on the xenomorph homeworld out
of revenge more so than anything else
and so because of that where this jockey
is able to kill you know a lot of these
Xenomorphs with the greatest of ease
really Shelly no no difficulty
whatsoever we end up heating up with
with Newt and Hicks essentially just
bailing out of the planet taking off
heading back to earth and then we
transition back over to Earth itself and
what we find out is that about a year
after these events have taken place
again because of the fact that it takes
a little over a year to get from Earth
over to the xenomorph homeworld during
this time when Newt and Hicks are
basically making the return trip we end
up finding out that some of these
individuals who were infected by the
xenomorph
basically survive the entire you know
massacre by bio national and so the
result was that the xenomorph
infestation began to spread throughout
the world that various people began
experiencing xenomorph
kind of exploding out of them we end up
having of course salvo J who survives on
a plane indicating that we're going to
see a xenomorph outbreak on this plane
we end up having neo various instances
where Queen aliens begin to manifest
where they begin to grow so the earth
has multiple Queens and then of course
we have the government trying to crack
down on everything by killing anybody
who is infected and killing every
xenomorph where they can but at the end
of the day it doesn't matter because
they grow so rapidly and they grow so
fast that there is there's almost no way
to stop the entire infestation process
and so what happens is a story
essentially ends on the idea that Hicks
and Newt are going to return to Earth
only to find out that were they left one
massive problem one massive mission
failure going to the xenomorph homeworld
they're going to come back to earth and
find that the entire earth has been
infected with xenomorph but with that
being said guys if you are new here two
comments explained you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you drop a like that you
get the sub but to become a member of
the Rob port and let me know if you guys
want to see more Z know more stuff like
this because it's really cool and it's
really interesting in terms of how it
all unfolds and what all happens but
anyway guys we're to go ahead and bring
this video to an end and I will catch
you all later peace
[Music]
you